[Música]
ustedes imaginan una vida sin talento
seguramente no todos tienen cara de ser
muy talentosos yo sí
en el colegio no era el científico ni el
atleta ni el artista
pseudopolítico líder estudiantil
un poco la analogía del partido de
fútbol
el que mejor juega pues nunca organiza
el partido porque preocupa por el balón
tampoco
cuando uno asume esa condición hay dos
posibilidades o no se estanca y asume
exposición dentro del montón
o unos inventarios se busca la vida
en ese momento fue que yo decidí
trabajar paralelo al sistema ser muy
crítico con la manera como las cosas
deben hacerse con los supuestos con el
sentido común con el derecho de las
cosas
en ese momento fue que decidí hacer las
cosas al revés
yo soy arquitecto
de ahora en adelante me voy a referir en
plural porque cuando no se tiene ningún
talento en particular pues depende de
los demás se trabaja en equipo se
colabora
y en realidad no creo mucho en la
individualidad ni en los momentos como
repentinos de genialidad ni mucho menos
creo que somos capas de conocimiento y
sobre eso
construimos de manera que hace 8 años
recibimos este gran proyecto en la
oficina
y la pregunta era qué hacer con una
antigua fábrica textil de 13.000 metros
cuadrados en la zona industrial de
bogotá
y llevaban
cinco años en estado de abandono
la respuesta obvia no
pragmática práctica sensata era
derrumbar lo vamos a hacer un edificio
de oficinas hacia algún edificio
genérico de vivienda
porque es qué sentido tiene preservar el
patrimonio industrial de la ciudad
y ahí empezamos a tener algunas pistas
de lo que queríamos hacer
y en este sentido
pues decidimos mantener la estructura
decidimos conmemorar el legado
industrial de la ciudad pero asimismo
hacerle un homenaje al espacio donde
decenas de personas habían trabajado
durante años
todo esto bajo una lógica aún más
absurda bajo una lógica de desarrollar
esto a través de un centro cultural
centro cultural en una ciudad donde él
el consumo cultural está muy
centralizado en el territorio
y muy limitado a actores muy específicos
y a pesar de que el barrio el galán en
puente aranda donde está localizado el
proyecto y su bar increíble no un barrio
que refleja
la clase obrera bogotana que construyó
esta ciudad hace 50 años un barrio
construido informalmente
auto construido pero con las mejores
calidades urbanas comercio en el primer
piso sentido de comunidad
porque ese espacio público pues qué
sentido tenía traer a la gente o tratar
de movilizar a la gente en una ciudad
clima extremo tráfico extremo etc
y ahí empezamos a tener ciertas pistas
de lo que queríamos hacer porque el
nivel de incertidumbre y de riesgo era
sobre todo para nosotros pues una
posibilidad
porque al final es tratar de hacer las
cosas bajo lo que el sentido común dicta
tampoco garantiza nada
de manera que convencimos al cliente
a que se embarcará con nosotros en la
aventura
y mientras diseñamos el edificio
tras cruzar la universidad de los andes
a que los estudiantes de arte se tomaran
el espacio se tomaron un espacio que no
tenía reglas que no tenía impedimentos
un espacio en el que uno puede hacer lo
que se le diera la gana básicamente pero
la idea no es estudiar los estudiantes
lo entendieron bastante bien no de esta
manera empezaron a inspirarse no solo
por el espacio pero por el sector
la potencia de la calidad de la zona
industrial de bogotá y de esta manera
inspirarse en lo que esta zona puede
ofrecer
y se apropiaron del espacio se empezaron
a generar estas dinámicas
las cuales no habíamos presupuestado no
sabíamos cómo iban a dar no sabíamos
impuestos no habíamos controlado tampoco
nos interesaba
y de esta manera se empezó a sentir pues
una atracción natural no un ecosistema
en el cual ya en este punto no sólo los
estudiantes de los andes' pero
estudiantes de la gran mayoría de las
facultades de arte de esta ciudad ya su
vez acogen estudiantes de todo el país
pues hacían lo que se les venía en gana
en este espacio
y cada momento cada mes cada evento era
una nueva posibilidad
en un punto sabíamos que estábamos en
algo no entendíamos muy bien que era
pero sabíamos que había un ecosistema
una atracción de algo que estaba pasando
estamos llamando una atención en
particular
a pesar de que no lo teníamos claro lo
que sí tenemos claro era que había un
nivel de producción cultural y de
producción artística específicamente muy
alto por medio de los estudiantes
de manera que lo que era antes pues una
fábrica textil empezaba a pasar a ser
una especie de fábrica de arte
en ese momento
y bajo el recurso que nos dan los mismos
estudiantes no hicimos la siguiente
pregunta que era bueno qué hacemos ahora
qué pasa si hacemos de esto una feria de
arte
pero qué pasa si hacemos una feria de
arte distinta como convencionalmente se
hacen las ferias de arte si no hacemos
una feria de arte basada en galerías si
no hacemos una feria de artistas
no veníamos del mundo del arte no
teníamos el aval del mundo del arte no
teníamos experiencia los elementos no
teníamos poder de convocatoria
la falta de credenciales naturalmente
nos hizo pensar de manera más ambiciosa
qué pasa si esta feria es una feria para
público no especializado
porque el arte
pues de una u otra manera está
encapsulada en lo que es el mundo del
arte y el mundo del arte tiende a ser
bastante cerrado pero el arte no es la
producción cultural no es cerrar la
producción cultural si algo es el piso
realmente democrático en el que nos
podemos parar como sociedad y
relacionarnos como sociedad
de manera que qué pasa si le producimos
un tenedor plural permeable abierto
masivo popular alarte
pero no solo eso qué pasa si en lugar de
hacer una feria
en la que el arte se vende a precios
inalcanzables como normalmente pasa
limitamos a que ninguna de las obras
pueda costar más de un millón de pesos
si hacemos esto les podemos cautivar un
público que nunca se ha interesado en el
arte así que activamos un público masivo
popular
nos podemos lograr apoyar a los artistas
emergentes que ya los conocíamos que nos
queríamos apoyar que los valoramos por
su trabajo
de manera que en ese momento estuvimos
la buena mala idea de socializar el
proyecto
evidentemente cuando contamos el
proyecto pero los comentarios fueron muy
negativos
usted no saben de arte usted no conoce
en el mercado
no sé no saben hacer una feria no tienen
tiempo
el mundo del arte no funciona así
y evidentemente pues eso se volvió el
aval principal para sacar adelante este
proyecto
[Música]
o
bien
[Música]
esto
i
[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
tiene
sí
[Música]
en él
hoy
luego de haber finalmente terminado el
edificio después de seis ediciones en
bogotá dos ediciones en barranquilla una
edición en ciudad de méxico cinco
ediciones del salón de arte y tecnología
voltaje del cual recibimos las mismas
críticas cuando decidimos hacerlo por la
falta de experiencia credenciales
conocimientos etc
luego haber apoyado más de 700 artistas
haber vendido más de 8 mil obras
pues este absurdo
se volvió un proyecto de vida se llama
la feria del millón
nosotros desde la feria creemos que
apoyar al arte emergente no es
darle una oportunidad a los pobrecitos
artistas que les toca tan duro
y apoyar el arte emergente
invertir en una sociedad que sea
críticamente más consciente de la manera
como se relaciona apoyar el arte
emergente es invertir en una sociedad
que sea capaz de contradecirse
distanciarse relacionarse pero vivir en
armonía
y aunque el sentido común diga lo
contrario
pues nosotros creemos que el futuro del
mundo y de la sociedad que queremos y en
la que creemos no está en los medios de
comunicación en el sistema financiero
mucho menos en la política
está en la producción cultural
la razón por la que yo creo en hacer las
cosas al revés
[Aplausos]
[Música]